aber hauptsache gestern habe ich mir
extra wegen mir nicht vor einen
haarschnitt diesem neuen sombrero
gekauften jetzt bräuchte nicht mehr
nicht wegen einem sombrero versammelt
denn ich hab' instagram gefragt was ich
mal wieder hochladen sollen und jeder
von euch beiden immer wieder blogs
hochladen das geht allerdings gerade
nicht während der quarantäne viele
meinen genen den ganztag an häufiger von
zwei kindern hochgeladen aber jeder
weiteren sonntag wieder lockerte hat
jedoch die lupe ladeluke
er geht
die besten
[Musik]
wenn ich bei mcdonald's bin greife ich
auch immer
völlig selbstverständlich dass
eigentlich verstörende an diesem video
kommt allerdings erst noch und zwar ist
das eine freundin von diesem mädchen und
hört mal ganz genau hin was sie sagt
eiskalt
[Musik]
ich frag mich jetzt schon nicht mehr
warum ich diese serie so lange mir
hochgeladen haben
haben wir auch irgendwelche vernünftigen
clips ich gebe euch also wirklich lupu
beste leben mit der community leser luca
das große dicke besser
macht spaß
sich das hier alles an
[Musik]
da frage ich mich wie ich da gelandet
bin wo ich gerade bin auf youtube
wie lang ist du noch deine weintrauben
sandra aber gut meine lieben freunde ich
war heute beim fräsen sursis
wunderschönes wetter draußen also es
gibt absolut gar keinen grund für mich
irgendwie genervt oder traurig zu sein
von würde ich sagen statt mit positiver
energie ins nächste video
[Musik]
ja ich frage
das noch total dohmen welcher mensch
kommt dann auf die idee seine beine in
einen pullover
1 kommentar das ist
ich meine ja du bist du dass du dich in
dein bruder eingesetzt aber wer schreibt
wäre mit hd da kommst du auf dein leben
glas eine empfehlung für dich da bin
hey ho liebst du dir das ist bei dir
gerade schneidet hoch machen wir drei
geschwindner in diesem nächsten
eingesendeten video hier was wir gerade
gesehen haben sind also einige jungs die
in einem fahrstuhl stehen
genau von den spielplatz immer
geschlossen eingeschlafen aber die
gangster gangster
gangster
weil er auf einen geschlossenen
spielplatz geht dem vater schweinefett
war in die hand
wer kennt sie nicht
die gangster die auf einem geschlossenen
spielplatz gene sich allerdings im
fahrstuhl festhalten weil sie angst
haben wenn paar sekunden später
was ist denn jetzt passiert
[Applaus]
die jungs sind steckengeblieben
im aufzug wegen dem typen dar
ihr seid ja ganz anstrengt ich weiß
nicht was du deine katze gegeben hat
aber die hört sich armin vogel
apropos vogel alter bei mir im
schlafzimmer im baum brüten gerade
irgendwelche vögeli verdammt ich würde
ich habe angst vor fertig ich weiß nicht
wie man dann so nah
die sind so groß wie kannst du so damit
leider handelt den mund von einem berg
ich wurde einmal getreten folge fährt
vielleicht deswegen auch ein bisschen so
ein trauma da ist ja noch 1
bist du selbst vielleicht auch euro wert
[Musik]
was jetzt schon als vor mir als ich
wissen was ich euch jetzt mal empfehlen
kann eine maske kostet fünf euro 99 und
vier davon als bundle sogar nur 19 99 um
der komplette gewinnen wird gespendet
ganz wichtig danke
für dieses aussagekräftige video von
deinem hund
[Musik]
auch bei dir bedanke ich mich für das
video von deinem hund
[Musik]
ach so ich meine ich habe
instagram gefragt ob irgend welche clips
habt ihr mir die zusenden können per dm
und so weiter und so fort aber ich frag
mich was man sich dann dabei denkt so
luca möchte dass wir irgendwelche coolen
lustigen dummen videos zu sein doch das
endet nicht gut
dass das geht auf keinen fall gut die
luke schule besser aus
[Musik]
nach dem super-g dass von diesem einen
tick tock hat er immer so kopfhörer
kaputt schneiden so airports verschenkt
so hell wie willst du bekannt geworden
egal gut kommt machen wir weiter mit dem
nächsten videoclip und ich glaube jeder
kennt das was ihr da als schaut einfach
selbst drei karotten kartoffeln zwiebeln
apfelsaft bin ich der einzige
oder ist es bei euch aus wenn die
beispielsweise nach unten gehen müsste
und ihr euch irgendwie beispielsweise
keine ahnung was müsste holen computer
ein baum und wegen des infekts wer muss
von unten einen computer einen baum und
desinfektion skill holen ich frage mich
ob ich bin lesbisch oder hetero bin aber
ich hasse einfach alle
[Musik]
ok mit der aussage würde ich das video
jetzt aber auch mal ganz schnell beenden
meine lieben freunde allerdings hat mir
noch eine person ein auto zugeschickt
von daher schaut euch mal das
[Musik]
meinen worten der kanzlerin löschen ich
habe immer ein passwort vergessen dass
das heutige video jetzt allerdings
wirklich auch beenden meine lieben
freunde wenn euch mal wieder luca
reagiert auf die luft schon gefallen hat
dann einen daumen hoch unter dem video
händler schreibt mir gerne in die
kommentare ob ihr tanzen könnt youtube
ist jetzt befinden uns allerdings auch
schon im auto um meine lieben freunde
und ihr könnt einfach mal die robe auf
den zwei die draufklicken wenn ihr noch
kein abonnent von meinem kanal seit denn
dann werde die aber dann von meinem
kanal und verpasst keine videos mehr
wenn ihr schon aber deshalb bin ich mich
freuen wenn ihr auf die glocke klicken
würde denn dann bekommt er eine
benachrichtigung wenn ich was neues hoch
laden und hier ist ein video verlegen
pass auf den zweiten kanal online
gegangen ist
klasse klicken